david spunt live on the north lawn david
what is the latest on this standoff
sandra the white house insists that big
tech is picking on president trump
this is a narrative the white house and
the trump team have been pushing for
several months right now it's the first
time facebook has ever done anything
like this
completely pulling down a post meanwhile
twitter has put up warnings
over the past few months about some
misinformation twitter froze the trump
campaign account
until it removed a video now the
controversial posts
surround a comment the president made on
fox and friends yesterday morning
both social media giants argue what the
president said was misinformation
about kids contracting covet 19. listen
this thing is going away it will go away
like things go away and my view is that
school should be open
if you look at children children are
almost and i would almost say
definitely but almost immune from this
disease
okay in a statement of fox news facebook
writing this video includes
false claims that a group of people is
immune from covet 19
which is a violation of our policies
around harmful misinformation
twitter writing the at team trump tweet
you referenced is in violation of the
twitter rules
on covet 19 misinformation the account
owner will be required to remove the
tweet
before they can tweet again now the
trump campaign firing back responding in
part quote
the president was stating a fact that
children are less susceptible to the
coronavirus another day
another display of silicon valley's
flagrant bias
against the president sandra expect to
see more of a pull and tug
between the trump campaign and big tech
especially over the next few months both
of these organizations seem to be
getting more aggressive